ABC News: From coast to coast in every corner
of the U.S. deaths from fentanyl overdoses
are soaring.
CBS News: The fentanyl epidemic in the United
States killed more than 72,000...72,000 people
in 2022.
USA Today: Most people who take fentanyl don’t
even know they’re taking it.
You can’t see it, taste it, or smell it.
Associated Press: And we know that this global
fentanyl supply chain which ends with the
deaths of Americans often starts with chemical
companies in China.
Gabrielle SIERRA: More than 100,000 Americans
died of a drug overdose last year, and at
the forefront of this crisis is fentanyl.
The illicit drug has been a leading killer
of young Americans for the last decade, and
while the U.S. has faced drug epidemics before,
what we are now encountering is truly unprecedented.
SIERRA: While fentanyl addiction and overdose
is a domestic challenge, it is also an international
one.
U.S. officials are looking abroad to China
and Mexico in an attempt to curb abuse at
home.
China, because it’s the leading supplier
of fentanyl precursors - the chemicals used
to create the drug - and Mexico, because it
is where much of that final assembly happens
before the drug is smuggled into the United
States.
SIERRA: Both countries are important in this
conversation, but today, we’re going to
focus on China.
Particularly because the current state of
U.S.-China tensions has strained cooperation
in a number of areas.
Controlling illicit drug flows looks to be
one of them.
SIERRA: I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is
Why It Matters.
Today, China’s role in the U.S. fentanyl
crisis.
SIERRA: Can you describe for us what fentanyl
is and why it’s so addictive?
Thomas J. BOLLYKY: So fentanyl is a synthetic
opioid.
It can produce an intense high, even with
small amounts, feelings of euphoria and happiness
on the individual who's taking it.
SIERRA: This is Tom Bollyky.
He’s the director of the global health program
here at the Council.
He is also the founder and managing editor
of Think Global Health, and he previously
worked in the office of the U.S. Trade Representative.
BOLLYKY: If you take too much, it can lead
to your body effectively shutting down.
And that is what happens to people who have
taken too much, which is in the fentanyl case,
not hard to do given its potency.
It is not that expensive to make.
And it can be made from relatively common
precursors, which makes it really a perfect
product for smuggling into this country, in
that small amounts can be used to boost the
effect of narcotics.
It can be easily hidden.
It can be easily made and sold for a tremendous
profit.
SIERRA: Fentanyl is actually an FDA approved
drug.
It was first introduced in the 1960s as a
powerful intravenous painkiller.
Currently, pharmaceutical fentanyl can be
used before surgery, prescribed by doctors
to treat severe pain after surgery or during
advanced stages of terminal illnesses.
SIERRA: So while the purest forms of fentanyl
have these legitimate medical applications,
fentanyl analogues - which are the synthetic
combinations of fentanyl and other drugs - are
primarily what appears on the black market.
SIERRA: And while pure fentanyl is approximately
60 times stronger than morphine, fentanyl
analogues can be anywhere from 600 to 10,000
times more powerful.
BOLLYKY: It's paired often with illegal prescription
drugs, heroin typically.
But it has slowly now made its way into being
combined or cut into other drugs like methamphetamines
and cocaine.
So as it became harder to abuse legal prescription
drugs, people began to shift to illicit prescription
drugs.
And it is in that shift, really around 2012,
that you started to see the rise or the increased
use of fentanyl, which now plays a major role
in most opioid overdoses in this country.
ABC News: Sophia had taken a Percocet not
knowing it was laced with fentanyl...Where
do you think you’d be now?...I think I could
have been in a worse spiral or, as far as
I know, I could have been dead...Bringing
awareness to this issue that that pill may
not be Percocet, that pill may not be Xanax,
that pill may contain fentanyl and potentially
could be deadly is critical.
BOLLYKY: It's an enormous problem.
Since 1999, drug overdoses in the United States
have killed over a million Americans.
For individuals under the age of 40, it is
a leading cause of death in this country.
It has been bad for some time, but it worsened
dramatically during the pandemic.
So to just go through the fatalities, which
paint only a limited picture of what this
has looked like, we went from, in 2019 just
70,000 people in this country dying from drug
overdoses, far too many.
That number jumped in 2020 to 93,000.
That's a third increase.
It jumped again in 2021 to 106,000, and then
it climbed marginally again last year to 108,000.
SIERRA: While that data is for all deaths
due to drug overdose, synthetic opioids including
fentanyl make up the lion’s share.
Opioid overdoses also inflict roughly $1 trillion
in economic damage every year.
SIERRA: Unfortunately, opioid treatment is
not moving fast enough to keep up with the
deadly demand.
Federal researchers found that in 2021, of
the 2.5 million people in the U.S. with an
opioid use disorder, only 20 percent received
medication treatment.
On top of that, the SUPPORT Act that invested
$20 billion into opioid treatment and prevention
in 2018, just expired last month - and Congress
is not making moves to reup the bill anytime
soon.
SIERRA: Can you walk me through the illicit
fentanyl supply chain?
Because the drug is clearly getting here somehow
and it seems very accessible.
BOLLYKY: Yeah.
So the dominant fentanyl supply chain into
this country starts with chemical manufacturers
in China.
The part of China that's involved with fentanyl
production or the precursors to fentanyl production
are really small businesses, small chemical
companies that are historically been under-regulated.
After the fentanyl is produced in China, either
in finished form or its precursors, it typically
is shipped to Mexico, where there are two
cartels that dominate the fentanyl trade.
It is packaged there either on its own or
cut into other drugs, which then make their
way into the U.S. via the same supply chains
largely that dominate the illicit drug trade
or smuggling into the U.S. generally.
What makes this so hard is that pure fentanyl,
just such a small amount can make a big difference,
that potency.
There is a recent estimate by a health commission,
the commonwealth commission that looked at
the scale of the U.S. opioid crisis, and they
estimated that just three to five metric tons
of pure fentanyl is needed to supply the entire
U.S. consumption of illegally supplied opioids
in a year.
So that is a relatively small amount and much
easier for them to smuggle, particularly when
it is cheaply made.
SIERRA: Historically, the U.S. has stayed
hyper-attentive to illicit drug trade happening
at our southernmost border, working with Mexican
officials to dismantle numerous pill pressing
and smuggling operations.
More than 25,000 pounds of fentanyl has been
seized at the U.S.-Mexico border so far this
year.
To put this into perspective, just 100 pounds
of fentanyl is lethal enough to kill 18 million
people, which is equivalent to the entire
population of New Jersey and New York City
combined.
SIERRA: Earlier this month the pressure yielded
a firm result: a powerful faction within the
Sinaloa Cartel, which the U.S. considers the
top fentanyl trafficking group, reportedly
banned their members from producing and selling
the drug.
SIERRA: Policy makers in the U.S. are now
calling for a counter-narcotic strategy that
cuts illicit fentanyl manufacturing off at
the source, which means relying on the cooperation
of China.
SIERRA: Could you walk me through China’s
role in all of this?
Zongyuan Zoe LIU: I would characterize China's
role in the fentanyl market, into two periods,
before May 2019 and after May 2019.
SIERRA: This is Zoe Liu.
She’s a fellow for China studies at the
Council.
LIU: And the reason I make this distinction
is because effective on May 1, 2019, China
banned fentanyl as a whole class in terms
of production or fentanyl precursor chemicals,
at least in the domestic market.
And before May 2019, at least, information
and data from U.S. Drug Enforcement Agency
as well as Department of Justice and other
places shows that China is the world leading
fentanyl export in particular to the United
States.
But the Chinese government always cites stories
saying that, “Well, there is no official
data or any indications saying that China
is exporting fentanyl to the United States.”
So, you see the tension there.
And the chemical component of fentanyl just
make it so easy to have additional derivatives.
So, given that China already produces a lot
of chemicals as well as a lot of money going
into the Chinese pharmaceutical market.
And knowing that a very important industrial
policy component under the Xi Jinping regime
is prioritizing life science and pharmaceuticals.
Yes, China is not the go-to type of a high
tech or most innovative area for drug technology
breakthroughs, but it is actually the second
largest pharmaceutical market in the world,
second only to the United States.
And some reports estimate that by 2025, the
market size of the pharmaceuticals industry
in China is going to be higher than $300 billion.
SIERRA: Oh wow.
And overall, obviously, our relationship with
China in terms of trade is huge.
LIU: Yes.
U.S.-China trade relationship is perhaps the
single most important bilateral trade relationship,
if you will, in the world.
And if we have to put a price tag on it as
of last year it's about $700 billion.
SIERRA: Woah.
SIERRA: And a big portion of this price tag
is pharmaceuticals.
Last year, the United States imported about
$10 billion in pharmaceutical products from
China.
That made up around 10 percent of the $100
billion in total revenue generated by China’s
powerful pharmaceutical sector.
LIU: Because China is already the second largest
market for pharmaceuticals, there are so many
- more than 5,000 of different varieties of
small pharmaceutical companies that are making
different types of chemicals.
So, the entire supply chain becomes individual
makers.
SIERRA: How does illegal fentanyl or fentanyl-related
precursors get trafficked out of China?
LIU: Inside of China, they can either directly
export or traffic through Hong Kong or Yunnan.
Yunnan is a border town between China and
Southeast Asia, and the capital city is Kunming,
which has for a long period of time, has been,
preferred, if you will, drug trafficking route
and so is Hong Kong.
So, conventionally heroin or cocaine, go through
Hong Kong or Yunnan and then through Southeast
Asia, the whole idea of the golden triangle.
And obviously, things produced in Afghanistan
or Southeast Asia like Myanmar or Vietnam
or Thailand could also go through this route
to flow into China.
And the Chinese government cracked down on
the drug inflow into the Chinese market, but
they are not necessarily paying the same amount
of attention to export.
BOLLYKY: China has a robust chemical manufacturing
industry.
Actually when I was in government, we spent
a lot of time working with trying to improve
the oversight of that chemical industry, which
was at the time, tied for substituting dangerous
products like diethylene glycol into products
called excipients, things you add to small
molecule pharmaceuticals to make them easier
to take.
And at the time, China was not regulating
its chemical industry at all if the products
were destined for export.
China has shown little historical appetite
in overseeing the export of products from
that industry.
The only way we made progress in the import
safety crisis is that it had risen to such
a scale and a high level of poisoning, and
these were regulated products by the FDA,
that China was legitimately worried about
its brand, its ability to export into the
United States.
Or for other partners, using Chinese products
in the supply chain to be able to export to
the United States, that they felt compelled
to enter into a memorandum of understanding
to do something about this industry.
SIERRA: In recent years, the Biden administration
has begun to crack down on fentanyl suppliers,
developing stronger counter-narcotic strategies.
Actually, our own Latin America studies fellow
Shannon O’Neil gave testimony before Congress
about the enormous human toll of the illicit
drug trade, and suggested partnerships with
our Western counterparts in Latin America
to reduce the supply of illicit drugs.
You can check it out in the show notes.
LIU: For the very first time this year in
June, our American Department of Justice indicted
four Chinese companies and eight Chinese nationals
for crimes related to making or trafficking
or the sales of fentanyl and fentanyl precursors.
Now, these four companies are based in China,
and the Chinese government reaction to the
Department of Justice indictment is that is
there is no base of it.
Because the profitability is so high, not
just criminal organizations in Mexico are
interested in it.
Actually, normal Chinese companies, if there
is opportunity for them, they are interested
in doing it.
SIERRA: But the U.S. has this unique problem,
and China somehow does not, correct?
BOLLYKY: That's correct.
So China has no incentive on its own to do
anything on fentanyl.
They view it as a U.S. problem.
And they will very vociferously contest representations
that this is a matter of China pushing products
onto the U.S.
Beijing's foreign ministry says no illegal
fentanyl trafficking happens between China
and Mexico.
Adding ‘it’s a made in the USA problem’.
It also criticized Washington for creating
obstacles in their anti-narcotics cooperation
by imposing sanctions on the country.
BOLLYKY: China's incentive for doing anything
on this product or around this class of drugs,
is really linked to their motivation to cooperate
with the U.S.more generally.
And that is tied to China's sets of requests
on areas that they would like to see progress
on.
And that's really where the relationship or
the cooperation with China in recent years
has broken down.
SIERRA: How about the rest of the world?
Are we alone in this crisis?
BOLLYKY: We are alone in having a problem
of this scale.
Opioid use, or synthetic opioid use I should
say has started to increase a bit in other
countries, but nothing close to the scale
of what we see in the United States.
And that has been one contributing factor
to why the geopolitics of addressing the supply
of these drugs and supply of their precursors
has been so hard, is that the U.S. is somewhat
anomalous in the scale of the problem.
The U.S. has started in more recent years,
or this year really in particular, to take
a twofold strategy of trying to get this back
on track with China to disrupt production.
One strategy has been to announce a global
coalition to address synthetic drugs that
the State Department is leading.
Secretary Blinken, Anthony Blinken announced,
that would have more than 80 countries involved
in a time bound effort to try to strengthen
the policies, the regulatory oversight around
synthetic drugs.
U.S. Department of State: We launched the
Global Coalition to Address Synthetic Drug
Threats in recognition of the scale of this
challenge, and of the need for strong coordinated
international action.
In July we convened the first ministerial,
joined by officials from more than 80 other
countries, and leaders from over a dozen international
and regional organizations.
BOLLYKY: This is an effort to try to shift
what has largely been a bilateral conversation
between the U.S. and China about how to do
something on these products, to try to create
some amount of consensus, some reputational
incentive, by bringing together other partners.
Can we multilateralize this, bring in more
countries, create a consensus around it?
So that's one part of the strategy.
The other part of the strategy is the U.S.
has started prosecuting or announcing indictments
of those small chemical companies or individuals
that are involved in the production of finished
fentanyl or fentanyl precursors for shipment
abroad.
So it is really trying to use both a bit of
a carrot and a stick here.
A carrot being more of a global coalition
to draw China into these discussions, try
to move it from a bilateral discussion.
And the stick of actually going after individuals
and companies.
SIERRA: Earlier this month, the U.S. Department
of Justice announced more charges against
eight companies and twelve of their executives
in connection with fentanyl distribution.
Here’s what Attorney General Merrick Garland
said at a press conference:
Forbes Breaking News: These companies advertise
the sale of precursor chemicals online using
different websites and social media platforms.
They then ship the building blocks needed
to create deadly drugs all over the world.
SIERRA: China hasn’t commented on the most
recent indictments, but after the U.S. unveiled
similar charges in June, China said these
accusations could actually undermine future
cooperation on fentanyl.
Shanghai Eye: The U.S. side should resolve
the issue in an equal, respectful, and cooperative
manner and lift sanctions on China’s anti-drug
agencies as soon as possible, so as to remove
obstacles to bilateral dialogue and cooperation.
BOLLYKY: I think China, when it is motivated
to oversee its chemical industry, has proven
itself capable of doing so.
It's a large industry.
This requires reaching down to lower levels
of enforcement.
We're talking about something rising up to
the Beijing level, that ordinarily is dealt
with more and on the provincial or local level
in terms of oversight of these industries.
You need that high level of attention for
progress to be made here.
But I am confident that when that attention
is given, China is very capable of action
in this space.
They just aren't presently motivated to do
so, and the geopolitics make it seem hard
to imagine in the short term how that's going
to shift.
The U.S. has definitely asked China on many
occasions.
And again, their argument is that they adopted
these regulations.
They dispute the proof that China's industry
is a dominant source of fentanyl imported
into the United States.
They really argue that this is a U.S. problem,
a blight on U.S. society that the U.S. is
trying to blame China for, because it shifts
responsibility elsewhere.
SIERRA: What do you think?
I mean, do you think it's fair to point the
finger externally when it's a problem we haven't
fixed domestically?
BOLLYKY: I think it's fair to point out that
China is contributing to a U.S. problem.
It is our problem ultimately, but it is one
that they are making worse, and they're contributing
to, and could act in a manner to mitigate
or reduce.
And they should be expected to do so.
China has of course, historically had its
own struggles with substance abuse in other
settings.
And in those contexts, was quite sensitive
to the role of other governments in that challenge
that it had.
LIU: This is not the first time that the world
is facing a drug abuse crisis.
And for that matter, China would cite the
West of exporting opium to China as early
as in the 19th century.
And it was also because of the first opium
war that China started to fall into these
hundred years of humiliation.
So, from that perspective, this is not the
first time that we are dealing with drug abuse
or substance abuse problem.
SIERRA: In the nineteenth and early twentieth
century, China was the target of foreign opium
exports, initially illicit, which spurred
a nationwide addiction crisis.
But after the communist revolution, a major
prohibition began, wiping out most of China’s
domestic production.
However, after the economic reform of China’s
trade policy in the 1980s, the supply route
for illicit drug trafficking reopened.
And by 2016, the number of officially registered
drug addicts in China totaled about 2.5 million,
having increased every year since the government’s
first annual drug enforcement report in 1998.
SIERRA: In this way, China’s addiction history
is a bit similar to ours.
The production and sale of OxyContin by Purdue
Pharma, controlled by the Sackler family,
helped spur a national crisis as opioid-related
deaths skyrocketed in the late-90s and early
2000s.
Today, fentanyl is hitting a U.S. market already
primed for abuse by the painkiller debacle.
SIERRA: Given China’s own history combating
drug use, their government should be empathetic
with the acute challenges the U.S. is facing
amid this epidemic.
But so far, they haven’t been too interested
in helping, saying that because China doesn’t
have a domestic drug issue, they shouldn’t
be expected to help other countries with theirs.
BOLLYKY: I think it's, from that standpoint,
reasonable to expect them to do their part
to address this challenge.
But fundamentally, it will not be solved unless
U.S. action is taken, more support is given
for treatment, more support is given to reduce
the demand for these products.
LIU: I think it's very easy for us, at least
for the American audience to think that the
Chinese government, even if the Chinese government
does not have an explicit strategy to poison
American people, they must have been not doing
a good job.
And I think that much is pretty clear.
This becomes this unifying thing that everybody
can bandwagon on and blame it on China.
It becomes this not just bipartisan, but also
unifying at a societal level saying that this
is bad.
And who is the largest supplier?
Who is the largest maker?
It is China.
The Chinese government indeed hasn't been
doing a good job in terms of enforcing the
substance control, especially with regard
to fentanyl.
Right?
And especially when you think about comparing
how they deal with heroin and cocaine versus
the way that it controls fentanyl.
But I would also want to point out that perhaps
the Chinese government's priority is not there
yet.
They have economic problems, and then security
concerns.
And China so far does not necessarily have
a fentanyl or opioid crisis, hence, it's not
necessarily up on the government priority
list.
SIERRA: It is unlikely that China would regulate
fentanyl for benevolent purposes - moving
it higher on their list of priorities in order
to help the U.S. take care of a domestic issue
that many feel we alone are responsible for
causing and solving.
But perhaps this tragic epidemic and China’s
role in supplying fentanyl could open a route
for partnership opportunities.
SIERRA: On the flip side, do you think that
the fentanyl issue could become an opportunity
for cooperation in what is otherwise becoming
a chilly relationship, that it could lead
to greater cooperation in perhaps other arenas?
LIU: Yes.
I do think this could be at least one area
for the United States and China to start,
rebuild or repair their relationship, because
fighting against transnational crime is of
the interest of both the United States and
China.
This issue matters for China for two reasons,
at least.
The first reason is that repairing the relationship
with the United States can start with something
as important for the United States or as not
so important for China.
So, in other words, this does not necessarily
take too much trouble for the Chinese government
to do, given that the regulation is already
there.
Just regulate fentanyl the same way as other
drugs, this could be a very important way
to repair U.S.-China relations.
Especially after several administrations of
the U.S. government have pressured China to
do it.
And the second reason it matters for China,
is actually at the Chinese household level.
I'm genuinely concerned that there may be
huge demand for recreational drugs inside
the Chinese market, specifically because of
the massive youth unemployment problem in
China.
The Chinese government stopped publishing
or paused updating youth unemployment numbers
as of last month.
And the latest update suggested that youth
unemployment was as high as about 21 percent.
So, when you have younger people who are disincentivized
to work and they are having a hard time getting
a good job that they desire, it's very enticing
and problematic if they seek recreational
drugs as a way of escape.
And you see that happen in the United States
in other countries, and there is no reason
to think that this is not going to happen
to China.
Therefore, it matters for China for domestic
reasons as well.
It would just become too late for the government
to regulate when it becomes a crisis.
LIU: I try to be an optimist.
But in this case, I'm sorry, I have to say
that I'm relatively pessimistic.
It is very important for international organizations,
for governments around the world to recognize
that this is the issue that everybody will
be challenged with one way or another.
And it is a good cause for the government
to cooperate in order to prevent the current
substance abuse crisis and the next one.
Unfortunately, so far, really, we don't have
effective multinational or international cooperation
on drug trafficking.
But perhaps at least the United States and
China for the sake of restoring their relationship,
for the sake of protecting the lives of their
own nationals, the life of their own nationals,
they are willing to take a step forward.
BOLLYKY: China, I am entirely confident, is
more capable of regulating its small chemical,
family owned in many cases, chemical companies,
than it is presently doing around the precursors
or finished fentanyl.
China is waiting for the right incentives
from the U.S. before it feels compelled to
act.
And I think it's fair for Americans to feel
in the midst of an epidemic where it's devastating
to families and individual lives, that that's
a pretty cold calculation being done on the
part of the Chinese government.
I think that's fair.
But fundamentally at the end of the day, people
need to understand that this is indeed a U.S.
problem.
We need to look ourselves in the mirror and
confront that, and be realistic in noting
that the only way to sustainably reduce the
opioid problem in this country will not come
from China, it will be coming from demand
side actions to reduce the use of fentanyl,
to provide greater access to treatment, to
reduce its potential public health consequences.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
If you ever have any questions or suggestions
or just want to chat with us, email at whyitmatters@cfr.org
or you can hit us up on Twitter at @CFR_org.
SIERRA: Why It Matters is a production of
the Council on Foreign Relations.
The opinions expressed on the show are solely
that of the guests, not of CFR, which takes
no institutional positions on matters of policy.
SIERRA: The show is produced by Asher Ross
and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Our associate podcast producer is Molly McAnany.
Our interns this summer are Rhea Basarkar
and Kalsey Colotl.
Production assistance for this episode was
provided by Noah Berman.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Mariel Ferragamo.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
SIERRA: You can subscribe to the show on Apple
Podcasts, Spotify, YouTube or wherever you
get your audio.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!